خذها إلى ما أقول إنه وقت إلغاء تيتانيك
[تصفيق
] لتتزامن مع الذكرى السنوية الخامسة والعشرين
للفيلم ، حيث يحاول مخرج الفيلم
أخيرًا أن يغلق الباب أخيرًا
على هذا السؤال القديم حول الباب الذي
فعلته روز عندما استطاع جاك
غرفة مناسبة على هذا الباب لعائلة مكونة من أربعة
نقاد يضيفون كلابًا لإثبات
هذه النقطة ، لكن الآن Nat Geo تقدم
إعادة تمثيل علمية
باستخدام مضاعفات حيلة مغطاة بأجهزة
استشعار تتعثر في الماء البارد ، هذه
هي الدعابة التي استشاروها خبيرًا
في انخفاض حرارة الجسم في غضون ثماني دقائق.
كان من الممكن أن يكون فاقدًا للوعي في هذا
المنصب وبالمناسبة قال المخرج جيمس
كاميرون للصحفيين إنه من الناحية الفنية
ليس بابًا ، إنه قطعة من الألواح من
صالة الدرجة الأولى ، حسنًا ،
مهما كان الأمر فقد تم
اختباره قبل أن أعتقد أن موت جاك كان
بلا داع. MythBusters  قرر
أنهما فقط إذا ربطوا سترة نجاة روز
أسفل الخشب ، كان من
الممكن أن يدعم الطفو الإضافي كلاهما
ولكن المخرج سي  أميرون لم يكن متأثرًا ، عليه
أن يموت الرجل الذي يسقط كاميرون
يقارن ذلك بروميو وجولييت في
السطر الشهير الذي تقوله لن أتركك
تذهب أبدًا جاك لن أتركك أبدًا ، أعدك
لكنني أكذب
هذا جدل في فيلم واحد
لن تغرق
كولبير وكيت وينسلت ، هيا يا حبيبي ،
فلنركض لشخصين ، لقد قاما بالفعل
بإعادة تمثيلهما ، ولم
تكن هناك حاجة إلى قوارب نجاة جميع الأيدي على مكاتب
السينما CNN نيويورك